elle a eu elle était très malade au mois
d'avril on sait pas si une bactérie
quelque chose qu'elle a mangé ou qu'elle
a bu ou si c'était une une intolérance
alimentaire mais ses intestins ont tous
sion se sont tourné complètement alors
même après quelques jours de
vomissements de diarrhées ou le dernier
antibiotiques elle n'a pas répondu
finalement on a fait des rayons x ont
cherché un blocage en avait pas puis
finalement ils ont péri d'urgence parce
qu'à leur papa si la nuit et puis elle
avait déjà perdu la moitié de ses
intestins depuis avec cette opération le
on a pu la remettre sur pied lyon est le
fait d infection urinaire à l'hes
ensuite des complications eu beaucoup
d'antibiotiques et pendant au moins neuf
ou dix semaines jean pas dire combien ça
coûte et peut-être autour de 3000 à
ceyrat mon mari y écoutera pas ça parce
qu'elle fait partie de la famille on a
quatre enfants fixer des choix qu'on
fait c'est ce casse tête si elle avait
été plus vieille on aurait peut-être
fait un choix différent je sais pas mais
le